I am a mother so here goes clay too is
insane maybe I'll have another kids say
so today we are gonna go eat a Seoul
sausage with a very good friend of mine
you guys know her from other videos
before like carpool confessions and such
as such that's not even a [ __ ] word
but the [ __ ] is crazy come back come
back
I'm gonna make that note so Ellen and I
as you guys may know we're both Korean
and the only way for Korean people to
bond is if we do it over a little
libations so specifically a little bit
of soju
so specifically Tom Toto if you want to
sponsor me let it happen now
yeah like that yeah because this is how
you get sponsorships oh you're
disgusting you're a mother and you're
you're a mother you can't use that
laughing everything yes I can my bad
I mean that's how I had a baby haha
you're a mother
drunk Ellen is probably the worst and
best thing on earth specifically because
she's already an excitable human being
so when you put alcohol into her body
could you imagine what she ended up
being like fun yeah yeah me too it
sounds like a mockery to the business
grandma
remember kids out we're drinking
responsibly will be taking uber later to
the pros so for perfectly okay
personally I don't like drinking that
much but to be honest with you this is
freaking delicious he's so good it's
dangerously good so if you guys actually
don't know whose sole sausage is they've
won season three of the great food truck
race on the Food Network so if you're
looking for great Korean fusion food
that's the place to go we're all here at
seoul sausage we take traditional
American flavors add a little curry
Sol - it there are poutine fries are
probably one of my favorite things that
they make now I don't generally like
poutine and I know that's kind of hard
for me to say because I know there's a
lot of Canada fans out there but poutine
to me in general is very salty and bland
but what Seoul sausage does to it it's
absolutely amazing it's a kind of 1814
so car B team is like a super pull apart
short rib and they put like pickled
vegetables on top and of course you will
have like this delicious fries and then
you have like this is delicious
creaminess on top of the green onions if
you've ever had poutine in Canada and
you eat this you'll know the truth of
how good a poutine can be now take a
bite oh my god just a lot of French have
a little bit of the pickled because you
need like that vinegary buy to break up
the fat okay okay here it goes
and it tell me what you're experiencing
will you be back Oh
like that was real good right
nice easy it's good Canada I'm sorry
if you ever had arancini before
basically it's going to be risotto
that's deep-fried into a delicious ball
now Seoul sausage does their version of
it where they take kimchi fried rice and
also curry rice and they turn it in to
this absolute deliciousness where they
put a little bit of like spicy mayo on
top and it makes your boner just pop out
right their pants it has like this
sriracha or like spicy mayo on top when
you bite this is absolutely delicious is
crunchy it's super savory and the
creaminess from this male out of this
world
put in your mouth yep how good is that
how good is that if [ __ ] guys [ __ ]
hey no inquiry and oh god things that I
always say about good fusion food is
that when you eat fusion food you
shouldn't say oh it's a mix between this
and that when you eat fusion food and
you say this good is just good as a dish
that it is that's when you know the
fusion was perfect I don't like it when
I eat you put on my ah it's a little bit
of this a little bit of that it's like
an in-between this is a completely great
dish on its own one of our most famous
dishes here is our tidy burger oh that's
one we sold on the great food truck race
it's a Korean barbecue beef patty say no
more on a bun with garlic jalapeno aioli
pickled red onions in a runny egg so if
you like high B which is that Korean
marinated beef that you guys always love
with that soy sauce that ginger and that
sugar we put that flavor into it
patting what a deliciously fried egg and
this wonderfully toasted bun and is
aioli and we're just gonna pop right on
top and watch distance and when I smash
it and we do this and that egg yolk
breaks
Finch bite into your sausage and let me
know at your dick I mean your sausage
and let me know what it tastes like
yeah what are you thinking great again
it's pretty damn tight a lamb and some
vegetables and kind of white sauce
damn straight yeah in your mouth this is
their Pope gave me so I think that spicy
wasabi mayo with a little fish roe
inside put a cockade on top we have a
deep-fried or negative all or triangle
right then we also have our delicious
seaweed salad on the side and that's
what I always talk about fat and vinegar
or something's just sitting to break up
the fat and this is that perfect
combination so make sure you guys want
to get some bomb-ass Poquette could even
get it here so sausage so you look happy
I'm so happy
watch this right here this is a pizza do
[ __ ] T the deep fried o- if you have a
Budong gene which is that burnt rice on
the bottom of the pot this is what it
reminds me of but it has like that oily
crusty deep fried goodness and just
don't know if you heard that but that's
pure rice crunch so Bom it's also try
some Korean fried chicken wings just how
mama used to make him work back in Korea
now a lot of cultures had their own
version of fried chicken right well
Seoul sausage does Korea very well
because they had their version called
the KFC now over these chicken wings is
going to be smothered in this delicious
sweet spicy tangy sauce and of course
just to cut through that richness they
add these little cubes of pickled daikon
Vince is about to dig in to this
delicious KFC Korean fried chicken get
on this [ __ ]
Oh
this is everything I've ever dreamed of
you know it's all sausage just kind of
started as a passion project you were
making sausages out of Chris's apartment
and you just took them out to festivals
and people seemed to dig them so we do
that every weekend and I just got to a
point where we decided to go full-time
within a cell swank sausages for livings
scion sponsor me I saw what you did with
Seoul sausage you hooked their Scion up
with this whole grill and deep fryer in
the back what's up what's wrong with me
sponsor me you know what that would call
that I would call that the fat mobile I
just witness greatness right now do you
have any idea that this car is my dream
come true but I want to be able to pull
up in a parking lot and just start
cooking my own food not for people just
for myself chilling with these two dumb
[ __ ]
look at this girl and her ashy ass shirt
was like she went through chimney
Dennis do a great job of dressing up
like they don't really give a [ __ ] about
life I think it's called like self
premonition is where they're telling
themselves eventually I want to be
homeless the other size extra ashy
forget this [ __ ] are you a chalkboard
the reason why I love soul sausage so
much number one not only because of the
good eats and the great drinks they do a
great job of fusion what I mean by that
is that usually when it comes to fusion
food people tend to mess it up a lot
they kind of make it into like two
separate entities and they just kind of
smash it into one with Seoul sausage
it's different it kind of turns into
this thing that I call ethnic American
food where it's not so much this it's
not so much that but it's it's those
influenced that create a new type of
cuisine or dish and that's what I love
about them so if you're ever in Little
Tokyo you want great drinks great food
go out there you might even see me
asking for free food because I'm hungry
I'm always hungry
oh look at that I like it
I want one reward to the museum together